2017.
A world divided
with only one thing that can unite us all.
No, not that.
Sharks. Why does it always gotta be sharks?
Yep, we're making America bait again.
This could be the last curtain call,
not just for America, but for the world.
That's right. This time. It's going global.
I have a bad feeling about this.
They're bigger,
stronger,
stranger.
Throw another shark on the barbie, eh?
This summer.
The phenomenon that swept the country four
times before is now taking the world by storm.
Literally.
That is messed up.
It's the next chapter of the franchise
that's been hailed as gloriously idiotic
and absolutely pointless.
It's a safari-nado!
Oh my god I just killed Bret Michaels!
Well everyone's replaceable.
The hunter becomes the hunted!
Oh the humanity.
Sharknado 5: Global Swarming
That's a huge shark.
That's no shark.
That's a shark-zilla.